you have a passion for wine and as some
do but you're so passion about you have
your own label well and I've actually
was very intrigued on a personal level I
was like I have not tasted your wine and
I was like before we go I was like I
just want to I want to work this into
the segment so I get it for free see
what I'm doing and maybe Andy would
guess about it sure I do i as the place
called I'm close sellers in santa rita
hills and peter and rebecca at work
owning and that is the winery and the
vineyard that I make my wine out of I
make and I work with Peter right and
I've become he took me under his wing
and he's mentored me for the last nine
years now
very cool and I'm involved with every
aspect of it so this is the Chardonnay
where's our glasses we got glasses yeah
we got glasses now here anyway
they put a spit bucket out here throw
that away we're gonna take an uber home
on this I want to be all liquored up you
get Drive after you drink wine Andy has
said that to more police officers
through a window drinking its water no
this is this is a Burgundian white this
is Chardonnay and what's fantastic about
the santa rita hills area we're not
three two one go
when I temper sense this is always
called Goldy Gogi is my nickname and
Gogi is the name of my wine
every year with the Pinot Noir every
year I changed the name to a family
member some nickname that is in my
family and but the Goldie is always the
Chardonnay that's all that will do that
will do this I got it we got one open
here all ready for you okay
all right so here you go so this is the
Chardonnay and what you want here is
something that's crisp light fun mm-hmm
something you could have with a nice
salad a salmon salad or maybe in the
afternoon with an apple and some cheese
well what a talk show yeah I want to
talk Joe Koren a talk show with Kurt
Russell yeah there we go
don't be still
oh man that is good fantastic huh all
right let's go to go to my cat okay
we're gonna go straight to it I'm gonna
start doing your plugs okay we have it
where's my oh here look Guardian to the
colony I got one for you with that and I
want you to keep this there's your Gogi
I get to keep to keep it go your dogie
thank you so much these are pretty cool
I need more wine found at home okay all
right I'm starting this remember my
childhood again this is where's your
thing that's right there all right so
this is this is this is my passion Pinot
Noir is I think the great the great red
wine it's complex and that is because
you blend all there are 52 pinot clones
and you take the in our case i take five
or six that i really like that i think
have been in barrel and are just ready
to go and you you take them it you take
them and you put them together and when
you get the right percentages you try to
create the perfect what smells fantastic
there giggling because once again and ii
started getting it into him kill you now
you know what before you drink i can
listen and drink at the same time with
your nose in there get your nose in
there and really get a good this goes
good with the white at the same time i
have to say that's what you want with it
that's i'm that's how the weight of rose
a
how do we have I've got others
there's one
can you give me paper I got this all
right get this all over my Shh this show
we can only afford one suit a week
this should be on the label but really
you should do one label this is my
sentence it's me going that's the label
you can have that
you